for decades the goal of big Tech has
been clear and absolute growth over
everything else regardless of what
obstacle came up they were willing to
push through no matter the cost whether
it was concerns regarding privacy or
data collection or predatory pricing or
monopolistic practices or antitrust
lawsuits or whatever big Tech kept
charging forward hoping to maximize
their user count and for the longest
time this strategy worked the more they
pushed the further they were able to
reach they were able to convince whole
new demographics and even countries to
adopt their technology and over time all
of this growth has allowed big Tech to
be some of the most powerful influential
and Wealthy companies in the entire
world but it seems that big Tech is
finally facing a challenge that they
can't just brute force their way through
Market saturation this was historically
something that most tech companies did
not even consider simply because their
target market was virtually everyone
with with an internet connection but
guess what everyone with an internet
connection now already uses most of the
popular services offered by big Tech
take WhatsApp for example in Brazil they
control
98.9% of the market in India they
97.9% in Italy they control 97% in
Argentina they control 96% and so on and
so forth and it's not like they can grow
in the countries where they don't
control nearly 100% either because the
rest of the market in these countries
aren't exactly open they're just
controlled by another big Tech offering
whether that be iMessage or Android
messaging and this is the case with
basically every major tech industry
Chrome has 3.2 billion users Android has
3.3 billion users YouTube has 2.7
billion users Facebook has 2.9 billion
users Instagram has 2.3 billion users
and on and on and on when you combine
all of these market shares you'll see
that big Tech already controls virtually
the entire internet in fact just Google
Netflix Facebook Apple Amazon and
Microsoft control 57% of all global
internet traffic so I think it's safe to
say that big Tech has officially won the
game so what
now big Tech reaching Market saturation
may not seem like a big deal after all
how hard could it be to just be the King
of the Hill and make billions every week
right well that would be true if making
billions every week was truly the end
goal for these companies for most of
these companies there is no concrete end
goal their goal was just to grow
infinitely and given that Tech is able
to reach a larger demographic than any
previous industry this strategy was
viable for decades but now that they've
reached Market saturation this goal
becomes a lot harder you're probably
wondering why does any of this even
matter couldn't these companies just
hang up their hats and call it a day and
enjoy Market saturation well they could
definitely hang up their hats but they
wouldn't really be able to enjoy it
because many of these companies would
end up losing hundreds of billions of
dollars because the only thing holding
up their mass valuations is the promise
of infinite growth take Apple for
example they're currently worth just
under $3 trillion but on an annual basis
they only make a little over a 100
billion now that's obviously an insane
amount of money but what we're really
concerned about is the ratio between
their valuation and their annual
earnings or their PE ratio which is
currently about 30 this means that if
you were to buy the entirety of apple
right now and they stop growing it would
take you 30 years to make all your money
back and even then on your $3 trillion
investment you'd only be making a 3.3%
yield on an annual basis AKA you took a
3 trillion 30 yearlong gamble with apple
just to end up making less than in a
high interest savings account or a
Government Bond as you can see investing
in big Tech at these valuations only
makes sense if you think that they're
going to continue to double and triple
and quadruple if you think that they're
just going to stay the same it's a
terrible investment for it to make sense
to invest in a stagnant Apple their
valuation would have to come way down
usually the standard PE ratio for mature
companies with stagnant bottom lines is
10 a lot of mature companies actually
have PE ratios less than 10 Ford is at
6.78 ryzen is at 7.55 and United
Airlines is at just
4.56 but let's give Apple the benefit of
the doubt and call it 10 this would mean
that an investment in apple would pay
back in 10 years aka the annual yield
would be about 10% or a good amount
higher than savings accounts and bonds
making the investment worth the risk but
for Apple to have a p ratio of 10 their
valuation would have to fall to $1
trillion which is obviously still a
massive amount but it's also $2 trillion
less than their current valuation and
it's the same case with the rest of big
tech for Microsoft to come to a p ratio
of 10 they would also have to shed $2
trillion Google would have to shed $1
trillion Amazon would have to shed 1.3
trillion and Facebook would have to shed
a $600 billion and I think now would be
a good time to mention that Apple's net
income has already been stagnating for 2
years Google has been declining for 2
years Amazon was briefly even losing
money and medda income was straight up
cut in half the only big tech company
that has managed to continue growing is
Microsoft and even that is marginal but
we don't even have to speculate as to
what would happen because this has
already happened in the
past this transition from hypergrowth to
stagnation happens in basically every
industry whether it be railroads banking
oil automotives you name it eventually
the exponentiality of the industry wears
off and the valuations and expectations
settled down this isn't to say that Tech
as a whole is done for there's plenty of
innovations that have yet to materialize
whether that be VR or AI or whatever
else but it's more than likely that
these new revolutions will be led by a
whole new generation of companies while
current big Tech Giants get left behind
just like gen One tech companies take
Intel for example these guys are one of
the most influential tech companies of
History they were basically the father
of silicon Wafers Intel's founder Gordon
Moore was literally the creator of Mo's
law and as such they enjoyed a
tremendous growth between 1984 and 2000
of
9x but moving into the 2000s personal
computer adoption peaked out everyone
who could possibly get a computer
already had one and pcsl started to
Crater in fact pcsls have been crashing
for over 10 years now but that isn't to
say that the semiconductor industry as a
whole stopped growing though Qualcomm
Nvidia and tsmc have all figured out new
market segments to continue exponential
growth the peak of the PC market however
marked the top for Intel who has been
struggling to recover for the past 23
years and there just one example D was
crashing so hard that Michael Dell had
to come out of retirement take the
company private and completely pivot to
save the company HP on the other hand
ended up splitting into two separate
companies and that's just within the PC
manufacturing industry Cisco was once
the world's largest company but after
their Peak they would crash 80% and they
have yet to recover and it's been 23
years it's the same case with AT&T and
Verizon and IBM and Panasonic and Sony
and several other gen one Giants the
most interesting thing about all of
these companies is that none of them
particularly dropped the ball it's not
like Xerox or yahu where they started
losing market share and revenue started
plummeting no these companies still
dominate their respective Industries and
fundamentally speaking many of them were
actually doing better than ever Cisco
for example is now making double the
revenue that they were back in 2000 and
Intel is almost Making triple the
profits but with their P ratios
constantly Falling Towards 10 all of
this fundamental growth has meant
nothing in terms of stock Returns the
only gen one company that I can think of
that actually over overcame this
quicksand was Microsoft and it was by no
means an easy battle it took Microsoft
exactly 17 years to climb out of this
bottomless pit and that's not even
accounting for inflation if we account
for inflation it actually took Microsoft
18 years to finally live up to their
dotom valuation and during this time
period Microsoft Revenue had to grow
fourfold and their net income had to
grow 2 and a half fold in other words if
investors Stop Believing in modern big
Tech growth story all of the companies
that we know would have to grow 2 to 3x
in terms of Revenue and net income
before they enjoy the same valuations
for Apple this means they'll have to
grow their net income from $100 billion
to $250 to $300 billion before they
enjoy the same $3 trillion valuation big
Tech CEOs are well aware of this and
that's why they're scrambling to keep
investor morale high and more
importantly racing to
monetize
likely the first big Tech CEO to come to
this realization was SATA Nadella when
he took over Microsoft he was taking
over from Steve balber one of the most
controversial Tech CEOs of all time
Steve had grown Microsoft's revenue and
profits by threefold but Microsoft stock
had fallen 36% throughout his 14 years
of leadership Satya saw this and decided
that he didn't want to play this game of
constantly creating the next big thing
and achieving infinite growth that was
clearly a Young Company's game and
Microsoft was very much a mature company
so what he did was transition Microsoft
into becoming a tech holding company
basically he settled for modest growth
with core Microsoft products and started
investing hundreds of billions in upand
cominging companies with a bunch of
exponential growth left just recently
they closed their $69 billion deal to
acquire activis blizzard but the truth
is that you can only do this so many
times eventually you get so big that
even a hundred billion acquisition
doesn't move the needle the second big
Tech CEO to realized this was Tim Cook
in late 2018 he realized that iPhone
sales were not only starting to stagnate
but decline so he decided to take
control of the narrative and stop
reporting unit sales for all Apple
products instead he started focusing on
services like apple music and iCloud
which was extremely successful but now
they're at nearly a billion paying users
and running out of iPhone users to
monetize the next big Tech CEO to
realized this was Mark Zuckerberg after
the pandemic boom Mark realized that he
had reached Market saturation with the
social media Empire so he decided to
start digging for new gold he committed
a hundred billion to the metaverse
changed the entire company's name to
meta committed $33 billion to a new
language model and tried to take on
Twitter but so far none of these new
efforts have quite panned out and that
brings us into s pitche arguably the
last big Tech CEO to realize this and as
such his solution seems to be the most
lackluster Google is basically just
doubling down on the cloud and packing
in as many ads as they can but again
they can only pack in so many ads and
take this so far which brings us into
the core issue at hand big Tech has
enjoyed massive growth and tremendous
returns in their pursuit to reach
everyone on the entire planet but now
they've actually done it and they facing
the real challenge which is not even
growing but simply maintaining their
Skyhigh valuations despite a stagnant
user base every big tech company has
chosen a different path to overcome this
new quicksand of high interest rates and
Market saturation will their efforts
actually pan out only time will tell but
looking at history one thing is for sure
it ain't going to be easy someone else
who's facing an exential crisis is money
burning startups who are struggling to
get more funding check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next
one